i'm going to talk about what i consider
to be the biggest mistake that most
language learners make
okay this is the biggest mistake the
biggest obstacle the biggest hurdle
uh
the biggest thing that prevents people
from
succeeding
and becoming fluent
whatever that means
and that mistake is that people stay
with the beginner
material for too long they stay with a
beginner book they stay with the
beginner course the beginner lesson they
never get beyond it
and it's quite unnecessary if you buy a
beginner book which i think is a good
thing to do if you embark on learning a
new language
that beginner book you can use it for a
year but you keep on going back to it
you don't try to master it you don't try
to
learn it understand it you don't have to
learn or remember the dialogues the
vocabulary the grammar rules nothing
it's just a bit of an initial guide
something that you go back to
regularly as soon as possible you have
to get away from the artificial
environment of the beginner course the
beginner textbook or whatever your
teacher has you doing in class you have
to get beyond that you have to get into
real
language